this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons from throughout
history
and today as we got a load of requests
for it he's going to be checking out the
varied arsenal of hot dogs horseshoes
and hand grenades all in glorious
virtual reality
you do however need the loading lever
replaced
with a larger loop because otherwise you
break your fingers
now in vr you don't have fingers so
that's fine if there are any other games
guns or mechanics that you want to see
jonathan break down do let us know in
the comment section down below
make sure to subscribe for more videos
exactly like this and if you want to
help out the royal army's museum and
continue to support jonathan's work
check out the links in the description
of this video right
over to jonathan
okay of course there first of all i just
want to say how nice it is to see
a muzzle loading firearm in any kind of
computer or video game
and of course what we've got here is
leveraging vr
to let you really experience something
of what it's like to load a muzzle
loading weapon
that's usually fudged in video games
this
pretty much nails it um and i gather
there are different ways to load
this thing as well but what we see there
is a complete
paper cartridge and then we see the
separate flask used for priming
kind of works pretty much how it does in
real life i suppose the only thing
that struck me is a bit unusual is that
the [ __ ] because it is called a [ __ ] got
a hammer
seem to go to full full [ __ ] both times
rather than
than half cop which is the sort of safe
loading position that
pretty much all flintlocks have i don't
know if that's the limitation of the
model in the game
or just the user putting it to full [ __ ]
you
could load from like a full cop it's
modeled on
some sort of reproduction kit so it
doesn't look very
classically antique flintlock um just to
prove the point i have one behind me
this is a classic british
military pistol smaller caliber than
the one in the game one in the game is
what we call musket 4
and this is a pistol ball this one's
dated 1742
marks the tower for the tower of london
where it was assembled
and it works just like the one in uh in
the game
i should really get the laundry done
tomorrow
the kalashnikov akm you can't really
have a shooting game without any play in
it the big thing that leaps out
is the grenade launcher not super common
to see
in video games full stop um but it's
well it's well done um
i've actually got one so the first thing
i suppose i would say is
it's fairly easy to get an ak right in
this day and age and
it's a decent 3d model um it's what
looks to be well implemented
and then the really interesting thing is
the great launcher so the
gp25 grenade launcher catch up here
to remove it and it mounts just like you
see
in the game it's a little bit more
physical um on the real thing
than just moving things around in
virtual space but um not far off
didn't quite catch how the sighting
arrangements were dealt with with the
grenade launcher but we're quite used to
judging by by eye
firing grenades and games so maybe
that's how it's done
uh we see the the player there doing the
something we see in reload animations
in first-person shooters the great thing
about vr is that
you've got actual objects with actual
moving parts which means that you can
take a loaded magazine and hit the
magazine catch
and knock out the empty magazine just
like you can in real life
and that's a legitimate reloading
technique for
the ak you can interact with these
models in a way that
you just can't in a normal flat game
pausing there so the winchester 1887
is pretty iconic and it's cropped up in
various computer games
over the years and i think probably best
known at least in my generation
because of terminator 2. and of course
we see in the clip there
the spin cocking that is possible with
lever action rifles or shotguns you do
however need the
loading lever opened up or replaced with
a larger loop because otherwise
you break your fingers now in vr you
don't have fingers
so that's fine the other risk of spin
cocking like that which was done by
john wayne originally by the way is
hitting yourself in the head
shooting yourself generally colliding
with parts of your body again not a
problem in um
clearly in this game but it's something
you're gonna you put it you don't put
an 1887 lever action shotgun in a game
if you can't
spin [ __ ] it here is one being an m1887
shotgun
this one is similar in configuration to
what we see in the game there but it's
got a shorter barrel it's more your um
t2 length actually but this one has not
been cut off with the stock
for stowing in a harley davidson
scabbard
the m1 garand or garand if you prefer
what can we say about that that hasn't
been said a thousand times before except
that
it's got such an iconic loading system
with the unblocked clip of eight rounds
that you push into the action
either the bolt closes or you close the
bolt and then when you've fired
your last shot you get that classic
resonant
ping sound as the clip that has stayed
in the gun to this point
goes flying out of the gun
the only thing you're sort of missing
well not the only thing but something
you're missing out of in vr is how
when when you load something the
ammunition just drifts into the gun just
drops in
no problem at all and you sort of i
think i haven't tried it myself but um i
think
you're missing out on the physicality of
of how much force it takes to press
that clip into the action on the plus
side you're not getting your thumb trap
and getting like a black fingernail or
something from the infamous
garen's thumb
the mp5 i don't like normally to say
what my favorite firearms are but if you
catch me off guard
and maybe i've seen die hard recently
the mp5 is
probably it looks like it handles
handles well um
case ejection as in some of the other
guns looks a bit
funky like just the stream almost looks
like a stream of static images which it
isn't
but the way the cases are coming out of
the gun doesn't look very
naturalistic the the um iconic
handling aspect of the mp5 is of course
the hk slap what you're supposed to do
is lock the
bolt open then put the magazine on and
then slap
the handle you can absolutely do it the
way we saw in the video there what we
saw there is um
someone i think remembering that they
really want to do an hk slap
and um putting a magazine on locking it
to the right and then
slapping it but just the fact that you
can slap it well it probably would have
been a riot if they hadn't implemented
that
the next interesting thing is the
modularity one of the accessories that
was
made available quite early on for the
mp5 was
some form of sound suppressing like
we're used to seeing suppressors screwed
on
and it looks like from this footage that
that's what's happening
the player is screwing the silencer on
with screw threads which is how
a lot of suppressors do work the hk one
doesn't
it works with offset lugs
and you push it on and turn and it locks
in place
we've got a level of realism here where
the players try to fit the suppressor
just by pushing it on the end of the gun
and then when they fire a shot it flies
off which i didn't notice at first
way more realism than we'd normally see
in the game featuring firearms
the ultimate leap in realism is that it
wouldn't even stay on
it would kind of fall off because of the
way the system actually works
they bleed mustard okay pause there
that's got to be the most
realistic depiction of a single action
army cult that i've seen
simply because it's modeling all the
aspects of loading and reloading the
thing we've got the loading gate
that you can open and amusingly exactly
what would happen in real life i imagine
if you weren't
really skilled with this thing you kind
of fail to push them in and some fall
out
and then coming to [ __ ] the hammer to
fire it and then to unload
having to open the loading gate rotate
the cylinder
push out the empty cartridge case one at
a time and um
i'm surprised i didn't anticipate this
happening but we actually see at one
point
using the controller to fan the hammer
completely impractical
never done in real life as far as we
know although i've seen it done in video
games
to actually be able to do it virtually
looks like fun to me
now that's a really interesting gun that
we've seen there that's the
the viper mark 1 which is a british
experimental submachine gun of
the very end of the second world war so
this this thing does show up in my new
book
on british ballpark firearms because
it's one of the relatively early
attempts really really nice to see a
very rare historic firearm depicted not
only in a video game but something where
you can really get hands-on with it like
that
looks to work as it probably does work
we don't quite know because we're not
going to shoot it it's the only one that
i know of
that exists there may be others let me
know if you do no but i don't think
there are
and um when it's pulled up to the to the
eye sort of aimed fire you'll see that
you can see there are no sights
and it's kind of cumbersome even in vr
and that's because this was designed
as a commando weapon for assaulting
over a beach and you can sort of see
from how it's shaped
that it's actually fought under the arm
one-handed use
so you're looking where you're shooting
and you're grasping it under the arm
giving you loads of control over recoil
but you've got no like no ability to aim
that's a fascinating historic firearm
and i'm really glad to see it
in this game
what's that we've got there an accuracy
international
bolt action precision rifle well it's
meant to be a three three
three three eight lap with a magnum
rifle which would make it an awm
arctic warfare magnum this is the arctic
warfare
which should be in 762 nato and i have
cheated and looked this up
what i gather has happened is that um
model available to bring into the game
was the arctic warfare they really
wanted a 338
rifle fair enough why wouldn't you so
what they've had to do is lengthen the
receiver on the bolt
and so it's a sort of hybrid sort of
version of the ai that
never existed
okay pausing what witchcraft is this
that's not how guns work that's not how
any of this works
so we see we've got a macro makarov pm
and a version of a desert eagle both of
them
get put in a plant pot and shake now and
what comes out is some unholy hybrid of
the two
like many made-up things i don't think
it would work because you've got
rotary bolts multiple lug lock-up which
needs
gas operation to unlock it and i don't
know if um
9x18 would have the sufficient
gas pressure to achieve that i don't
know who knows let's never find out
thanks for watching everybody i hope you
enjoyed that run through just some of
the guns that are available
in hot dogs horseshoes and hand grenades
which i very much would like to play now
if you'd like to we've got links in the
description to donate
to the royal armouries museum or perhaps
even become a member
otherwise we'll see you next time
[Music]
you